[Music]
all righty and welcome back to the show
you know conor mcgregor is one of a kind
he's a talented fighter but he's a much
bigger entertainer
he helped the ufc grow wildly about six
seven years ago his personality and
irish stories captivated fans and
non-fans alike
he had a chance back when mcgregor was
gaining popularity now to sit down with
him
he had just what come off a big win
looking forward to his future in the
sport
it's not a day that i wake up and do not
pinch myself and be grateful for
everything in my life
you asked conor mcgregor and he'll tell
you he was destined to be the best
fighter in the ufc i knew everything
would happen he was here
i cannot believe it i can't believe it
but i
i could believe it and i did believe it
so that's why it happened in fact he's
ready to take over the organization
just give him time the zuffa head office
that's where i feel i will head when
this is all said and run
i feel i will have an office bang in the
middle of vayner and lorenzo's office
you know dana's office is there
lorenzo's office is there
and my office will be banging the middle
growing up in dublin a big office wasn't
in his plans he was more concerned about
taking out the bully on the block there
was many times where i
fought and there was many times where i
backed down
so i was no different than any young kid
sometimes you win sometimes you're
little
mcgregor started boxing as a teenager
and quickly moved into mixed martial
arts he witnessed his first ufc fight in
2009 and said that's what i want to do
he quickly rose up the ranks and found
himself in the ufc
and hasn't looked back his last loss was
in ireland in 2010
as one of the two biggest stars in the
sport i asked conor who would be most
proud of his accomplishments
his father or his mother i think they're
both equally proud of me i mean to see
their son
achieve their dreams they are both big
fans of what's happening here they
my father is a big big fan of the sport
and since since he saw my success and
you know
he showed about every fight and then my
mother i could be doing anything and my
mother would have my back
27 years old and living the life he
always dreamed his fans call him the
celtic tiger
or the irish ali they even say the ufc
stands for united for connor this story
has never been told before there has
never been another man in this position
even in this sport you know before me
knowing how to how to register to win
inside the octagon
let alone headline events let alone win
world titles
the former plumber from dublin is right
where he thought he would be even
challenging boxing's pound for pound
king floyd mayweather he recently told
the guardian he'd dismantle him in
seconds in a fight that would generate a
half a billion dollars
who knows but that's why they're united
for conor
in the ufc